all right so I've heard Comics talk
about this and you know sometimes I
couldn't get my mind around but wrapped
around it but I heard a comment I want
to say his name but he goes when I'm on
the road all I can think about with my
kids and I can't wait to get home on
Mondays right do you have that feeling
when you're on the road and you can't
wait to go home to see your kids well
first of all I'm gonna get home on
Sunday he's a piece of [__] father if
he's coming home on Monday
um
no no I'm kidding I do I I feel like now
when I feel like okay so two things one
when I first you know parenting Journey
because it takes years to like I still
don't have to figure it out I don't
think I think it's just the whole
thing's a journey but I would quite
often be on the road and even though I'm
doing what I want to do which my own
happiness and everything will only if
I'm happy it'll be transferred to the
kids so you have to be happy first it's
not a selfish thing for you you need to
be happy first just like you need to
breathe first so you can do it for the
children so what I would do though a lot
is I would go on the road and feel this
sense of of guilt because I was leaving
half my brain at home with the children
and then bringing half my brain to the
comedy clubs and that wasn't doing
anybody any good I'm not there for them
and I'm not there for me so now what I
do is when I'm somewhere I'm fully both
my feet are here I'm in LA with you guys
that doesn't mean I I'm not thinking
about my children that doesn't mean I
don't miss them but like I would quite
often be like I shouldn't be I should
just always be with the kids and that's
not that's not being a good parent that
that's not that's not necessarily you
know uh doing what's right by them so
now I'm always here so when I and it
helps me actually conserve a lot of
energy so when I do get home you know
this this is a long trip for me this is
seven days away from them wow so it's a
lot that that's a lot but I say you know
what I'm gonna do this once and then
when I get back home to them I will be
100 present and fully engaged with them
and for how long for um until you know
if somebody wants me to do the pot I'll
do that but you're on Rose you're on the
road oh yeah no no on the road no I so
what I do now time is actually a more
valuable currency to me than money I
fully agree yeah I fully the money
doesn't mean anything it does not I mean
it means something because of survival
and sure sure but it's like I don't have
you know like like we have people with
money can only say that no but right
right there right you and I understand
right no because I do flu
no you guys are absolutely yeah you're
with you because you got a little bit my
point is that when you don't have that
right that's not no I'm listening I do
listen to you you do listen to me and
I'm listening now yes go ahead
okay so I think though that you can just
you can just adjust your life if you
have less money you all you really need
to do is get your basic needs met your
basic survival needs met to be happy
someone in a homeless shelter right now
can be happy if they're not happy it's
because they're comparing their life to
something that somebody else has but if
you can just find a way do your basic
needs are met then I think that you can
be happy I have all these things I'm not
happy
because I want you to I want to I want
you to sexualize me a little bit but
also like be dominant I want you to call
me for the rest of this podcast
five four three two
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
good afternoon and good morning to you
whenever you're listening at any part of
the globe you could be in the
anti-architects you could be on an
island somewhere you know what I mean
just you know doing whatever people on
the island do today I woke up I didn't
know who the [__] was going to come
today you know because I don't give a
[__] but um some people that do some
people I don't you know what I mean this
particular I didn't until he came but
yeah but it's a good one uh we have a
good guest he's
um from New York I met him a long time
ago on opening Anthony him and I did it
and we had breakfast with Opie remember
that was really nice I talk about a lot
and I had a connection anyway he's a big
Madison Square Garden comic uh huge
comic huge podcaster Young
right of the people that live in this
country right they don't have they only
have 400 in the bank for emergency yeah
but their basic needs aren't met he's
just saying what I'm saying is that
those you ask those people if time and
money well their basic needs probably
aren't met I'm just saying like I'm just
saying like yes I understand you know
more money you know more money doesn't
obviously we know it doesn't equal more
happiness I'm saying those you you would
be like if you gave somebody in another
country in like a small village in India
or something like that if you gave a
nice small Republican Village in India
four hundred dollars and their basic
needs were met they would have such a
sense of happiness but in America when
this whole idea is you sh you can't be
happy unless you have the house with the
white picket fence and so what I'm
saying to you is that when you're
worried about you're going to get
evicted you can't feed your kids right
and right because
so you're not happy if your basic needs
are met then you shouldn't be able to
find happiness
but you won't so most of us won't
because we want more and we're always
comparing to others yeah but comparison
is a thief of Joy said by Teddy
Roosevelt right never forget that to
your point say that again comparison is
the thief of Joy comparison is the is
the thief of joy you know it's my pain
comes from comparing of course you know
this you guys know this about me yes
that's my number one pain you can't
compare I drive down the street anyway
um so I I mean I agree with you then yes
but to your point like even in the
Philippines like with my family like
some of them live in like abject poverty
but I'm telling you they are so much
happier than me in so many ways like
they're just general outlook on life and
their ease about them it's like you know
but like you said as long as they have
like potable water they have certain
things and they're I I look at that I'm
like [__] like you guys are just happier
yeah and like people who like if they're
listening and they're like [__] you know
it's all about the money you're just
it's anger it's not it has nothing to do
with me or you it's it's always
typically always with yourself it's like
you are not uh you're you're comparing
and you're wanting you have this
insatiable need to want more that's why
you're mad with if you're only making
500 you have a sensational need to get
more for me with comedy if I want to
make a certain amount of money the
reason why I won't go unless it's an x
amount of dollars is because for me I'm
not gonna the only reason money makes
sense for me is if it buys Freedom so I
need a certain amount of money to buy me
the freedom to have with my children and
if he does do that I'd rather spend
because what I'm really you know I think
about two Banks right you tell me okay
you know our agents will say oh but
you'll make more money we have the same
agents I don't know who you're with Jews
me too obviously WME no with me nope
okay don't say our agents then okay so
so they are mine are better and
rightfully so yeah and rightfully and I
have Ken jeong's agent
and rightfully so they're going to want
more money make it make that's fine but
I think of two Banks the money bank and
then the time bank so how much time is
it that's the more valuable bank to me
because that's the that's I can't
replace I can always replace my you
could always make money yes I don't care
if you're actually stupid home you can
always make money it's America time
you're not going to get back let me ask
you this is a real question I'm you know
I'm about jokes and I mean and verbal
play you know and Shadow play and all
those things but let's be real for a
second okay
so there's a lot of times people go
um I get offered a lot of things right
and they go hey can you want to go to
Australia for this or do you want to do
this it's for
a pretty good decent amount